we can hurtfully nor the first solution
like that now in fact this is completely
easiest one to memorize sign of what
will give me a heart
politics thank you and you can see pi on
6 is nice and close if you drew it well
it should be about 1/6 of the way to the
next intercept after 0 now this is a
little bit trickier okay so I'm actually
at this point Karachi to put your hands
down and you can finish cracking in a
second I want your minds engage with
what's happening up here ok here's my
first solution how do I get my next
solution going in the positive direction
I mean I know I could actually get this
one but the next solution don't tell me
what the answer is how do I get a
geometrically
this went forward plant six right how do
we get to this one let me draw it in for
you
Hey hopefully you remember back from
your quadrants even if this is what
you're not relying on like you get acute
angle here to get the obtuse angle
that's sort of equivalent in that you
say PI - right and then to get the -
reflex angles how do you get this one
time PI plus and what about the last one
- pi - by the way 2 pi minus 2 pi -
right - yup I now have you look over
here huh well look at this second equal
sick and quadratical it's PI you can see
by the symmetry take away the same
distance okay now you can tell me the
answer which of course is okay now once
I've got that pair of solutions you can
see your life just like I do because I I
can get every on the solution by taking
those two going forwards to two pi
radians right so can you tell me what
the other solutions aren't what's this
next one gonna be
I'm adding two pi which is which is 12
PI on should be 13
which means the next one will be 1717
and then let's do our last pair dishonor
babes
25:29 right because it's just one pilots
extraordin
okay so again watching carefully right
how am I going to wrap these two things
together there are two ways and they're
both legitimate I want you to understand
but here's the first way I can kind of
consider that there are two overlapping
sequences of solutions in two
overlapping first you've got the acute
angles right you got this acute angle
then you've got an acute angle plus 2pi
and you've got make you hang with us for
pi and then you have an acute angle plus
6 PI ma the same kind of thing that was
happening here right so I could say he's
my best bunch of solutions
that X is equal to the term racist exact
to n PI right that fit even PI's right
plus the little what you get
okay for you know integer values
available but then I've got these obtuse
values for X that I also want to solve
Frank so what did we say these ones we
said was pi take away violence is right
and that this one was it read three-time
- plant seeds and then 5 PI - plant
seeds right so I'm gonna write this into
a tumor say it's 2 n PI + you see this
is the obtuse angle that relates to the
acute angle that I wrote the top does
that make sense
you got the you know I need your prime
minus theta but of course I can do a
little bit more simplifying here right I
could write this as like I can take out
a factor of Pi do you see that I can say
it is 2 n plus 1
what's a pun right now to end that gives
you all the even integers 2 n plus 1
won't you people feet blood ones does
that make sense
you see how I did that um I thought
about from the juice anglers point of
view and then I said well I can factor
that out and I've got one sequence very
even parts and then another sequence for
the odd one does that make sense
so this is fine okay I will point out
just while I'm doing that is 2n plus 1
all it really is doing for me is giving
me odd numbers like 1 3 5 negative 1 etc
2n plus 1 is a fine way to do that I
could just as easily if I wanted to have
said 2 n minus 1
this is a bit weird we're not really
accustomed to this right it's like wait
in my books usually 2 n plus 1 & 2 n
minus 1 are different right but in the
case of general solution they are not
different do you see why
what is the job of this um this to
Empire or the Empire perform or this to
n plus 1 or 2 n minus 1 its job is just
to give me all the different values of
Pi hours and stuff on it and route back
and forth from ok so being its only job
is to give me this case give you all the
even numbers in this case is to give me
all the odd numbers ok both of these
formulas will do them just one for me in
fact they're both the general terms of
an AP which will always give me all of
the odd numbers 1 3 5 7 central it's
just a different value where okay so
these are both fine they're both
legitimate if different answers but they
give you the same solutions does that
make sense
so what do we got here let's just pause
I drop this and I'm gonna put that line
I think that would be kind of like the
nice one right I need both of them
yeah I need one for the even is in one
for the odds and then I have captured
all my solution okay that's alright but
I kind of don't like the fact that I
have to say of one series of solutions
sequence as I say
one sequence of solutions and I have to
say two things to capture that one
sequence it's kind of awkward enough to
look at an and didn't have to do it for
cosine so how can I have waited for sine
and I don't know how long a
mathematician was staring this problem
until the flash of inspiration came
through that by a bit she must be really
satisfying if she finally wrote down
what she's after
what you're after what we're after is
one function that can do both of these
jobs right we want to function that will
for even values go forwards see that
forwards forwards forwards but for odd
values doesn't go forward it goes
backwards because he it backwards here
backwards you see what's happening okay
so if you've got probably running out if
you've got one more color all right I
want you to show you've got zero pi plus
then you've got one pi minus
sorry 2pi plus 3 pi minus 4 pi plus 5 PI
minus if only there was some function
that based on the number you put in if
it's even he goes that way and if it's
odd it goes that way and here's what
they worked out they said look at every
multiple of Pi you want every single one
so I'm going to n PI not to Empire
what I want to add something which goes
back and forth facetious but back in
fact we call this the switching part of
expression
this is what they came up with thing
about this guy for a second and I need
to finish it off in either Clancy's on
think about negative 1 to the power and
it's brilliant right you put in any even
value what will happen if you put an
even value 10 what happens to the
negatives they always cancel each other
out
right you can put 0 2 4 6 8 in there and
you'll always have an even number of
negative signs that always cancel each
other out ok but if you put in an odd
number like 1 or 3 or 5 you'll always
have a negative leftover it's ingenious
right so what we've got here is a single
line that does the job of both these
lines okay so you can see it's kind of
one spot more elegant if you could wrap
your head around this thing and the fact
that it's a bit confusing because 10 has
a period of Pi that's why you're the
formula has n PI in it
cosine has a period of 2 pi so that's
why it's got a tomb a planet but be
careful we try to do something deeper
with something to take care of this
backwards and forwards
the unis site has a period of July we
crafted a formula to take these two bits
and put them into one does that make
sense so lastly to finish it out I can
say generally if you want solving sine x
equals any constant you'd like then for
any domain X is going to equal to n pi
plus negative 1 to the N times what
again sign in oh it's very good but
whatever angle right what are the basic
will do for you sign e of us okay